Traductor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
Revisor: Ciro Gomez
Si quieres echar un vistazo
a los manuscritos de Marie Curie,
tendrás que firmar una exoneración
y ponerte equipo de protección
para protegerte de
la contaminación por radiación.
Los restos de Madame Curie también fueron
enterrados en un ataúd forrado de plomo
para mantener la radiación, que fue
el corazón de su investigación
y probablemente la causa de su muerte,
bien contenida.
Originaria de Varsovia,
en la Polonia ocupada por Rusia,
la joven Marie, cuyo nombre de soltera
era Maria Sklodowska,
fue una estudiante brillante,
pero enfrentó barreras desafiantes.
Como mujer, se le prohibió
seguir estudios superiores,
así que en un acto de desafío,
Marie se matriculó
en la Floating University,
institución secreta que brindaba estudios
clandestinos a la juventud polaca.
Ahorrando dinero y trabajando
como institutriz y tutora,
finalmente pudo mudarse a París
para estudiar en la reputada Sorbona.
Allí, Marie obtuvo un título
en Física y Matemáticas
sobreviviendo
principalmente con pan y té,
y a veces desmayándose por hambre.
En París, Marie conoció
al físico Pierre Curie,
quien compartió su laboratorio
y su corazón con ella.
Pero ella anhelaba volver a Polonia.
A su regreso a Varsovia, sin embargo,
encontró que lograr
una posición académica como mujer
seguía siendo un desafío.
Todo no estaba perdido.
De vuelta en París, el enamorado Pierre
la estaba esperando,
y se casaron rápido convirtiéndose
en un formidable equipo científico.
El trabajo de otro físico despertó
el interés de Marie Curie.
En 1896 Henri Becquerel descubrió
que el uranio emitía espontáneamente
una misteriosa radiación
similar a rayos X
que podría interactuar
con una película fotográfica.
Curie pronto descubrió que el elemento
torio emitía una radiación similar.
Lo más importante,
la fuerza de la radiación
dependía únicamente de
la cantidad del elemento,
y no era afectado por
cambios físicos o químicos.
Esto la llevó a concluir que la radiación
provenía de algo fundamental
dentro de los átomos de cada elemento.
La idea era radical
y ayudó a refutar el antiguo modelo
de átomos como objetos indivisibles.
Luego, al enfocarse en un mineral
súper radioactivo llamado pechblenda,
los Curie vieron que el uranio solo
no podía crear toda la radiación.
¿Había otros elementos radiactivos
que podrían ser responsables?
En 1898 informaron de
dos nuevos elementos,
polonio, llamado así por
la Polonia natal de Marie,
y radium, la palabra latina para radio.
También de paso acuñaron
el término radioactividad.
En 1902 los Curie extrajeron
una décima parte de gramo
de sal de cloruro de radio puro
de varias toneladas de pechblenda.
Una hazaña increíble en ese momento.
Más tarde ese año,
Pierre Curie y Henri Becquerel
fueron nominados
para el Premio Nobel de Física,
pero Marie fue ignorada.
Pierre se mantuvo firma en apoyo del
reconocimiento bien merecido de su esposa.
Y así, tanto los Curie como Becquerel
compartieron el Premio Nobel de 1903,
convirtiendo a Marie Curie
en la primera mujer Premio Nobel.
Bien financiados y respetados,
los Curie estaban en una buena racha.
Pero la tragedia ocurrió en 1906
cuando Pierre fue atropellado
por un carro tirado por caballos
mientras atravesaba
un cruce congestionado.
Marie, devastada,
se sumergió en su investigación
y asumió el puesto docente
de Pierre en la Sorbona,
convirtiéndose en
la primera profesora de la universidad.
Su trabajo en solitario fue fructífero.
En 1911 ganó otro Nobel,
esta vez en química por su descubrimiento
anterior de radio y polonio,
y por su extracción y análisis
del radio puro y sus compuestos.
Esto la convirtió en
la primera, y hasta la fecha,
única persona en ganar premios
Nobel en dos disciplinas diferentes.
La profesora Curie puso
sus descubrimientos a trabajar,
cambiando el panorama de la investigación
médica y sus tratamientos.
Abrió unidades móviles de radiología
durante la Primera Guerra Mundial,
e investigó los efectos
de la radiación en los tumores.
Pero estos beneficios
para la humanidad
pueden haber tenido
un alto costo personal.
Curie murió en 1934 de
una enfermedad de la médula ósea,
que muchos creen que fue causada
por su exposición a la radiación.
La investigación
revolucionaria de Marie Curie
sentó las bases para nuestra
comprensión de la física y la química,
y caminos fructíferos en oncología,
tecnología, medicina y física nuclear,
por nombrar unos pocos.
Para bien o para mal, sus descubrimientos
en la radiación lanzaron una nueva era,
desenterrando algunos
de los mayores secretos de la ciencia.